In many respects, Benedict
the 16th was the pope who got a bad rap
nearly 24 years
as Pope John Paul,
the second doctrinal enforcer.
And a German childhood
lived in the shadows of Hitler's
Nazi regime.
He was often on flatteringly
referred to as God's Rottweiler
or the Panzer Cardinal.
Years of negative
publicity
caused many of his accomplishments
to go unnoticed
He was the first pope to go green,
making the Vatican
the first country in the world
with a zero carbon footprint,
putting solar panels on its rooftops
and bringing in electric vehicles,
including a hybrid popemobile.
He was cardinal and pope
during the years
when the Catholic Church's sex
abuse scandals came to light.
And he spearheaded
the Vatican's efforts toward a zero
tolerance policy.
It was too little, too late for some,
but it was Cardinal Ratzinger
who organized the Vatican's
response to the scandal
including creation of a special office
at the Vatican to handle cases
extending and in some cases
eliminating the statute of limitations
for victims.
And as Pope publicly apologizing,
I am deeply sorry for the pain
and suffering the victims have endured.
And their shoes.
And since,
I suppose I had to share in suffering.
One of his first acts after being elected
pope was to condemn a popular
church figure, Father
Marcel Maciel, for sex abuse,
something which had not happened sooner
because of Markle's
close friendship with Pope John Paul.
The second
The high profile
condemnation Defuzing concerns
that Benedict wanted to cover up scandal.
However, after his retirement,
he suffered a reputational blow
when a church commissioned report found
he knew
about allegations
and failed to act
against a pedophile priest
while he was archbishop in Munich.
40 years ago,
Benedict denied the allegations
and the surprise
for which he will go down in history.
Being the first pope in modern times
to resign
showed that
the man everyone
thought of as a traditionalist
was unafraid of bucking
the biggest tradition of them all
that a pope doesn't step down.
It is me, as in graduation data too
true to form.
He made the historic announcement
in Latin,
saying
he lacked the strength of mind
and body to continue as pope.
But this tough traditionalist
was also a softie.
He loved cats.
Chico and Contrasena were two to
and classical music.
Mozart's Clarinet
Concerto was a particular favorite
within the Catholic Church.
Pope Benedict
was a towering intellectual figure,
one of the last to have attended
the historical church council.
Vatican two in the 1960s.
He authored hundreds of books
and articles
and was as much a hero to conservatives
as a controversial figure for others.
A famous
speech in Regensburg in 2006
that Benedict said was misinterpreted.
Questioning the link
between Islam and violence
sparked protests against the Pope
from some in the Muslim world.
His resignation
introduced the biggest change of them all
an era of two living popes
Although he vowed to retire to a life
dedicated to prayer
at a monastery inside the Vatican,
the pope emeritus
continued to exert influence
during the Francis papacy,
weighing in on debates
over sexual abuse and celibacy.
By writing articles and books
well into his nineties,
charismatic a elder,
he had retired as pope,
but not as a major player
in the Catholic Church,
an influence likely to continue
even after his death.
Father Reese, let me ask you this, your
just initial reaction to the news of Pope
Benedict's passing.
Well, of course, it's not a surprise Pope
Francis announced
earlier
in the
week that
the pope that Benedict was very sick
and declining
and so
we knew that this was going to happen.
But it's still a time to mourn
his passing,
but also to celebrate his ministry
of service. To the church.
And Delia,
just want to get your perspective
in terms of what Pope Benedict's legacy
is to you.
Well,
personally, I have known and followed
Pope Benedict and Cardinal Ratzinger.
I was actually taught theology
by a former student of his.
So I have
been fairly deeply involved
with Cardinal Ratzinger theology first.
And then when I came to the Vatican,
I, of course, met him personally.
And one of the things that sticks out
about Pope Benedict
and when people ask me about him
is the dichotomy
between his public reputation
and personally meeting him.
He it's very
kind of
alarming to sort of meet him in person
when you realize he's such a sort of kind
and humble and a person of a great
intellectual and culture full breadth
so that he had the capacity to focus
in on you
and say something
about whatever
you were talking about,
which you hadn't
thought of before in a fresh and new way.
I think there's very few people
who are original thinkers
in such a way
that Cardinal Ratzinger and Pope
Benedict was.
I think that
in terms of his passing,
it is the end of an era
for the Catholic Church.
He was the last pope
and cardinal to participate
in the Second Vatican Council,
which was a major event
in the life of the church.
And I think that he has
he is respected by both progressives
and conservatives
for his intellectual breadth.
It's what he wanted to do.
A professor, a theologian.
In fact,
he tried to resign several times
under John Paul.
The second he eventually did
resign as pope.
This is a man who didn't want to be pope.
He said a few days after he was elected,
when he heard his name
being called in the Sistine Chapel,
he felt like he was being led
to the guillotine.
This is a man who felt
he was called to be a theologian
and write his books.
And I think that that is the legacy
that he leaves to the Catholic Church.
Father, is
there are many ways that we will,
of course, remember former Pope Benedict.
But perhaps for most people,
it will be the fact that he stepped down
something that hadn't been done
in hundreds of years.
And I'm wondering
just how controversial
was that at the time?
Well, it was a big surprise at the time.
No pope had done this in 600 years.
And the result is that now
future popes are going to find it
much easier
to resign
if their health deteriorates to the point
where they can
no longer function in the job.
This is important
because modern medicine
can keep the body alive
long after a person is capable of
doing such a stressful job as being pope.
So it's important.
And the fact that he who many consider
a very conservative pope
was willing to do this
allows future popes to do it with
with no challenge at all.
And, Delia,
you know, obviously,
we've been hearing comparisons
between Pope Benedict and his successor,
Pope Francis, you know, I guess.
Tell us a little bit
more about their differences and
and how different they are
from each other,
and especially in terms
of their leadership
in the Catholic Church.
Well,
in terms of
their leadership,
of course,
they're completely different
personalities.
I mean, Pope Benedict,
as I said, was not one
who wanted the job of pope
because he understood
that he did not have he was an introvert.
He didn't have the ability to meet
a lot of people
all day to be
in front of the cameras
to make those gestures of John Paul
the second or Pope Francis.
They're sort of naturals
on the world stage.
Pope Benedict didn't have that
I wanted to mention
also in terms of his resignation,
that Pope Francis just two weeks ago
said in an interview
that he has already written
a letter of resignation in the case
that he should become incapacitated.
And I think the resignation of Pope
Benedict had two aspects.
One, it showed
his great interior strength
when he spoke
about his resignation afterwards.
He said he spoke about
he was very serene about it
because he spoke about it with God.
He had a very deep spirituality
and he was very sure of himself.
In that way was a very courageous move.
I mean, absolutely floored everybody.
But Pope Francis
just two weeks ago said,
you know,
I've written a letter of resignation
in the case
that I've become incapacitated
and nobody blinked an eye.
And that's
because Pope Benedict
had the courage to do that first, Amara,
And real quick, Father,
I was
just thinking on the fact
that Pope Benedict had to follow
in the footsteps
of the incredibly popular Pope John Paul.
The second and I'm wondering,
just how difficult
would that have been for him?
Well, I think it was difficult,
although they were very similar
in terms of their theology
and their
policies with regards to the church.
They were very different personalities.
You know,
Benedict really at heart
was a German professor.
He was he saw his role as a teacher and
this is what he always wanted to do.
And this is where his stress was.
He wasn't the greatest manager.
He did not surround himself
with really excellent people.
But he was someone who clearly
articulated the tradition of the church.
Whether that was convincing
for everyone or not, his is the question.